what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here alright so since I did the DC TV
arrowverse cross over stuff press on
Earth X I figured it's about time I just
catch up on the solo shows themselves at
the flash and arrow especially I'm
picking it up with the flash episode or
o.9 don't run this is the mid-season
finale like we mentioned earlier can
only show ten minutes of footage on
YouTube full-length video reaction over
on our patreon so become a patron eject
today if you'll want to check that out
[Music]
Oh snapped a lifetime supply of store
credit why don't we think that we needed
[Music]
what is happening oh damn
[Music]
my deepest congratulations on your
wedding
[Music]
[Music]
frosty melted away I've come for you
Kady oh he did tell him but bigger
oh [ __ ] who are you my name is Caitlin
snow when I hear him say enters hospital
I think that's where we are this close
to him for a while your said there done
that blonde lady she took you to God I
don't understand why this is happening
to us
Dominic do you know what a metahuman is
people with abilities people like you
they're a commodity especially yeah
listen I'm gonna be honest with you it
would be very difficult to fix what she
did to you even under the best of
circumstances with the right equipment I
feel that my head doesn't even hurt
which is a minor miracle but that shard
what a fracture caused permanent lot of
skills okay with our brain deficits oh
damn I smell a new romance you have
telepathic abilities can you hear what
I'm thinking Raymond
when did I get my powers a couple months
ago I took the bus to my job at the
airport TSA when I got there it was like
everyone was yelling at me screaming bad
that Mouse was moving the only works
when I'm close enough to season god I
would kill for that ability
I'd also hate it but I love it too I'm
gonna do
I'm scared to I like this actor
[Music]
good what what just happened clever
where is she the East Wing of C no it's
in your hospital this has been closed
for years
reach over Mason and leave all that
[Music]
it was a beautiful your head breach
[Music]
it is very nice lady
[Music]
those white girl dreads came straight
from the 90s
[Music]
yeah
if you want to give your phone number we
didn't like each other
[Music]
we built that cell so you can bring your
way around I didn't run just stood still
really fast you vibrate and faster than
the arcing process like your wife said
your brain may be smarter than mine but
your body it's still human it's over do
it
so from mr. Allen
[Music]
looks like spider-man
[Music]
mom Barry
[Music]
gave it Andy
[Music]
[Laughter]
that was a great way I thought they
brought that back
[Music]
Merry Christmas how could they just
celebrate Christmas right now they know
to vote I wanted to do so I just wanted
to say it was wrong of me to say the
killer frost is better than you because
the truth is no one you know a gift came
from you through one of those death
holes that you call a breach oh well
looks like gypsy came too I guess
wait this is a breakup cute I thought
things were going to the well with New
Jersey that makes two of us alone that's
not a breakup Kiba should open that when
you're alone no no no if she's gonna
break up with me only here why no no
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
don't move on can't believe
Dominic I'm so glad you came comment
this is Joe thank you know he's a
handsome fella else's bitchin that's
good
thanks my compliment but the guy you
just helped say one new guy in this
group and that's me know if I'm gonna
get a code name just to bring some ideas
about my powers
I hereby christen me brains
[Music]
oh [ __ ] guys that is so intense oh man I
thought we were just gonna get some like
fun Christmas episode of the flash that
plot was woven together incredibly well
holy [ __ ] I did not see that coming
because I thought it was cool how at the
beginning of the episode they're
establishing that DeVoe he's gonna be
transferring his bow is mine to someone
else's body it's a lot of aguilar around
a lot of movies is the theory of doing
something like that I did not see that
twist coming that was so well handled as
the episode was progressed and I'm like
okay we got these two storylines but
they seem to really just be here to
serve
iris West storyline of her having to
learn how to become a better leader then
they got to that twist ending that was
so brilliant because suddenly both
storylines just perfectly coincided at
once oh we were just watching it unfold
before our eyes and they had set up
little wrinkles of information and hints
that they would probably do that because
the guy who devote put his mind into hey
I like the guy who plays the vote I mean
not playing him anymore but I liked him
so I'm kind of bummed to see him go but
the new DeVoe I think is a good actor
and I thought they were setting up like
a romance with Caitlin snow and him so
it's a flip that edges every bad guy so
freaking clever and then oh man and then
des Vosges body at Barry's apartment I'm
having to make a choice whether or not
to run and him deciding to stay I'm so
glad that the show has already returned
and that I'm come running a little late
to this so I could just watch the next
episode I don't wait so that was a
brilliant twist because first the first
twist was brilliant it was like a good
saw ending but I felt like we watched
because the first twist was brilliant
and then the second twist were putting
Devoe's dead body there and planning on
Barry that that perfectly was set up
because what everything was leading up
to how Barry got a restraining order cuz
he was caught stalking him this
character this villain is so smart I
really love the way they've been
handling the thinker because he is a
brilliant villain and I'm just come here
going I don't know how the hell they can
beat this guy I really doubt that ending
really oh I got my heart notes
Katee Sackhoff is is really over the top
in this show she's alright but I like
what they did with the plot integration
of her care
having it all tie together his
oftentimes you feel like a lot of these
plots are just sort of be stories that
they're using as filler so it feels
essential now and I really like how they
evolved Ralph's character because it was
game to a point where it's like this
guy's just a douchebag and to have him
have this turn and wanting to be a
better friend and learning how to do
that I think is really nice even the
Irish stuff I did enjoy even though I
was first think you know this is all
just to serve Iris's storyline and we're
getting a nice Christmas episode this
thing just really pulled some great
twist clever ass writing on this show
dude oh well only two can shoot 10
minutes of my reaction on YouTube the
whole whole episode is on patreon so
become a patron eject today you guys can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification valued notified every time
where our videos is up next one I got to
catch up on arrow and then the flash
again dinero